m dans un coin de pourri du pauvre paris
une plainte à ce l'état vieux bistrot de
nulle part au gala à ce site à leurs
fins ils te font du vin première classe
on va voir impassible nectar ici n'est
pas assez mais si tu as causé qu'une
armure dassier m'a de la race août à ce
velours ce petit blues de malades
bientôt nous dit-on les petits bistrots
de la périphérie ne seront plus qu'un
souvenir
à paris même en dépit de la mode des
peuples et des drugstores près de 120
café disparaissent chaque année mais qui
s'en aperçoit anonyme interchangeables
dans leur décor de chrome de plastique
et de néons
ils ont transformé peu à peu en simple
endroit de passage ce qui fut si
longtemps le lieu géométrique une
certaine forme d'évasion
ce café d'autrefois café d'habitués léo
larguier le décrivait ainsi le café est
une oasis
on laisse en entrant beaucoup des soucis
clan n'a frais en été chaud en hiver
c'est le puits sur la route monotone la
bonne auberge tiède où l'on se fait
servir un groupe bouillant où quelques
boissons glacées il tient de la place
publique et du salon l'homme qui demeure
un instant sur la moleskine devient
sociable et bienveillant
son atmosphère et fortement obtient
souche et ceux qu'ils ont respiré s'en
passe difficilement
et y at il beaucoup d'endroits dans une
ville observé par ailleurs vaudoyer l'on
souhaite aussi enduré est aussi seul le
grand attrait de la terrasse de café et
d'y rester si l'on peut dire un passant
sédentaires de ne pas quitter la rue de
continuer à faire partie d'elle dans une
grande ville comme paris un des passe
temps les plus attachants de l'amateur
de terrasses et d'imaginer les idées cas
dans la tête le monsieur où la dame qui
passe et points seulement les idées mais
les patients les manning les inavouables
ou attendrissant secret dès qu'un homme
ou une femme a pris place dans un
endroit public il cesse d'être naturel
au contraire la plupart du temps l'homme
de la rue ne se soucie point de
l'amateur de terrasse de ce voyeur
public qui à deux pas de lui le regard
de passer
les terrasses bien sûr sont restés mais
où sont les cafés d'antan quelques
vestiges sur les murs quelques autres
dans un musée
[Musique]
qu'on ne s'y trompe pas toutefois pour
nostalgiques que puisse être aujourd'hui
la visite de cette salle du musée
carnavalet
les cabarets à vernon et auberges du
temps jadis était sans doute plus proche
du bistrot de brassens que de celui de
léo larguier jusqu'aux dernières années
du dix septième siècle on ne trouvait en
effet si l'on désirait se réunir hors de
chez soi que des pièces en fumée
brouillant tout mobilier rudimentaire la
clientèle de ces bouges se composait
essentiellement d'ivrogne et si racing
wallon la fontaine et molière s'y
retrouvaient souvent la tradition admet
que ces témoins pour y confronter des
idées que pour y sacrifier abacus
abondamment tradition qui s'est
perpétuée d'ailleurs comme chacun sait
et qui évoque t si quelques images
datant du premier tiers du siècle
dernier
or vers la même époque
balzac dans une intuition fulgurante
confiait un jour à un ami j'ouvre en
plein coeur de paris un café comme on en
a jamais vu je fais trône et george sand
au comptoir un qu'en pensez vous voilà
une dame de comptoir à succès
gauthier ne refusera pas de me servir de
garçons de café ne voyez vous pas dit si
tablier au ventre il fera une recette
d'enfer quant à moi j'aurai la serviette
sous le bras
les jantes ou organisant tout veillant à
tous et nous vendrons du mellino ce que
c'est aucune importance
aucune importance en effet ou si peu
cent cinquante après le triomphe de
potton
la grande révélation du café au parisien
c'est la visite de l'ambassadeur du
grand turc soliman hague à albi 14 ans
769 prokop a lancé en somme le café
après quelques essais infructueux au
moment où justement il est devenu à la
mode
la famille de prokop était venu en
france avec les médicis lui eni vers 750
à palerme nous amuser gentilhomme ont
ruiné et il travaille la foire saint
germain chez pascal enfin arméniens ou
vendre du café justement au monde la
foire mais on vend du café d'une manière
ambulante
on amène une tasse de café au au
carrosse des dames qui s'arrête et il
fait son apprentissage de comines et il
a certainement gagner un petit peu
d'argent et ils désirent s'installer à
son compte et jette son dévolu sur le
procope qui était à l'époque un
établissement de bains
il ya eu pour lui la chance que trois
ans après en 789 la comédie française
s'installe juste en face son
établissement
c'est donc devenu le rendez-vous des
auteurs le rendez-vous des comédiennes
le rendez vous de tous les gens lettrés
et le début de la gazette littéraire de
la critique parce qu'on est discuté des
pièces il aurait fait comme il en
existait beaucoup leurs effets au
procope une taverne qui recevait des
rivaux et des truands certainement le
succès n'aurait pas été avec lui mais il
a des choristes ont l'établissement
comme un salon qui n'était jamais vu
auparavant dans un ternissement public
il a mis des lustres au mur des glaces
et il recevait les gens comme on reçoit
des familles les gens venaient vite les
salons du procope on ait parlé on est
discuté on n'est pas bons on ne venait
pas pour ses livres et le café en plus
de ça donne en d'esprit over
[Musique]
que reste-t-il aujourd'hui des cafés
artistiques parfois des noms des murs
dans le meilleur des cas
verlaine ne reconnaîtrait pas la source
ni paul fort la closerie des lilas
plus près de nous le cyrano qui fut un
des hauts lieux du surréalisme n'est
plus qu'une brasserie pour touristes
seul saint germain des prés à renouer au
lendemain de la seconde guerre mondiale
avec une tradition politico littéraire
qui datait du début du siècle on la
cultive encore de francs
comme mon père a fondé ce prix irène
khan trentaine d'années maintenant
il était entouré par toute une clientèle
militaire acteurs d'intellectuels
le chant qui s'intéressait à littérature
bonjour comme ça l'idée est née et
pourquoi ce gazon n'auriez pas un prix
littéraire et du pourquoi pas même
aujourd'hui oui tout à fait par hasard
mais il se trouve au premier étage il ya
une réunion du cercle a nié nord à cinq
reprises il faut pas diviser
je viendrai corps et âme imprégné la
nature être toujours présent à jamais
transmuer mon coeur palpite radan
l'incarnent averous aleris à liège
donnerai mes yeux des grands films à
bouche et dalles de mes cheveux au vent
un sou +20 à la mère celle de l'âme ont
de l'avancé sur jc de l'arabe que le
grain noir des mots éclatant soleil
tarde de l'unrwa et fleurant et alice
mais acres digital j'allumerai les feux
des floraisons suprême et de
métamorphose eau terre air flammes
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un qui est ancienne table
si sans avoir besoin de lever de changer
de position ont simplement en levant les
yeux sur les glaces on voit ce qu'il se
passe derrière lui voit les champs
cliente voilée gentil sors toi les
grimaces que les gens peuvent tout faire
et il est il est quand même dans
l'ambiance contente par conséquent
passionné d'une façon effective il
s'isole
il a quand même une vision globale de
l'ensemble des choses c'est vers 1910
qui abandonnant montmartre quelques
peintres jusqu alors regroupés autour de
frais d s'établir à montparnasse
grâce à lui à ceux innombrables que les
suivis le carrefour vavin n'allait pas
tarder à bénéficier d'une renommée dont
quelques grandes brasseries demeure le
symbole la grande époque a commencé
juste avant la guerre au début c'était à
l'automne et à côté avait un petit café
que les par l'as où on a fait même de
l'exposition de tripoli après cette
bonne période
et quelques années après c'était la
coupole
le ses fastes date de la création de la
maison en 1925 et ce sont les
décorateurs et architectes de l'époque
et qui ont contacté les
les écoles les plus représentatifs de ce
moment là où l'on croyait les plus
représentatives il y a grunberg assez
connu les nordiques génie qui a eu
beaucoup d'influencé quartier marie
vasiliev précurseur du cubisme et
beaucoup d'autres qui ont dénommé
chapeau qui travaillent à chercher à
ouvrir toujours quelqu'un qui vous
offrez un café avec elle croise en eau
quelquefois même un sandwich on pouvait
pas mourir de faim en tout cas les
étrangers prenait qui a de bons shelley
chez les français et les françaises
probablement profiter de ces caractère
spécial où sont les deux russes ou deux
le polonais surtout les russes surcroît
à deux pas de la coupole à petit cafés
d'apparence pointer ici par le moindre
souci de montmagny faire
rien que des peintres et des sculpteurs
entre eux un peu comme en trois fois
[Musique]
les jeunes français par exemple tu as
dit sur le dos me tienne le gaming va le
caïman le cayman s'est fait votre image
il venait ici et il me disait bonjour 15
ans ont beau jour iphone mais c'était
[Musique]
super c'est un grand faim et de bon
coeur un jour il y sujet c'est un vrai
moment d'une page tout temps n'est pas
retenir son jeu wii mais général non je
crois que saint germain face à mont du
temple et de décollage désir a le
plaisir la période
le fait de verre deux frères la première
fois que j'entrais dans un café dit le
sage jeu fut extrêmement étonné d'y voir
ce que j'y vis et des discours qui
frappèrent mes oreilles
[Musique]